walmart plus  is a new membership that helps save  families  time and money so they can do more of  what they love  and this year so many families have  missed out  on important moments because of covid19  so  tell me did you have a  once-in-a-lifetime event on the books  but the year had other plans were you  about to say i do  until the year said no you don't well  walmart plus to the rescue they're going  to deliver some deserving families  missed moments with a plus post a video  or a photo on your social media page  explaining  what you missed and why you want a plus  up  experience by using the hashtags hashtag  walmart  plus up and hashtag contest  and include at walmart because you never  know  you just might even see me there  [Music]